tell me please just briefly is there
something about the phenomena of Conor
McGregor that is unique what is it that
is happening what has happened with him
what does he mean what does he mean into
UFC what happens to him now that our
post Mayweather fight what is he an
example of easiest of an outlier a
pioneer how will he be regarded what
does he represent is he an entertainment
product easy a great athlete is a
combination of all those things what
does he mean for the sport of UFC and
what do you think will happen in mixed
martial arts and boxing do you think
we'll see more of those kind of events
well you're never gonna see another one
like him right because he's a unique
person he's literally being himself
you're going to see a bunch of people
try to mimic that and in a sense he sort
of mimicked the people that came before
him like the Chael Sonnen x' and the
Muhammad Ali's and the people that were
really good at talking [ __ ] the
difference is that what Connors been
able to do he's the first guy in the UFC
that's been able to do that that's had
spectacular results and also showed his
real character in losing and then coming
back and winning very quickly afterwards
at the same guy like the Nate Diaz fight
mmm I think that was a very important
character exposing fight because he lost
a fight he got humbled and then he
jumped right back on the horse and then
wound up winning and then he comes back
and blows Eddie Alvarez out of the water
to become the first to division
concurrent champion in the sport I think
he's a unique guy in a very in it's
almost like we don't have a word strong
enough unique is not really strong
enough word so he's founded on ability
in a very basic way he's got brilliant
ability ability massive he's incredibly
smart and very he's very innovative in
his techniques and his approaches and I
think he has phenomenal coaching as well
all the animal movements there what the
[ __ ] is that walk well he's just kidding
what is that thing that he does we throw
so amazing what does he mean doesn't
mean this blows mummy he's doing it
cocky on me out
ok when I come out and stay sometimes
it's just an amazing thing to do with
the body
yeah peacocking you say looks like oh my
god this guy [ __ ] out it's doing he's
letting the other guy know that he's so
loose he can kind of strut with his arms
like rubber bands flying around but I
mean he's a combination of a lot of
things he's a brilliant team John
Kavanagh his coaches a brilliant coach
he's got you know of amazing jujitsu
coaching and striking coaching in his
mind he just he understands how to apply
these things and his ability to perform
under pressure is fantastic you saw that
in the Mayweather fight I mean even
though he lost that fight he hit
Mayweather with some pretty good shots
and he won the first three rounds
against the greatest boxer of all time
so ordinary I mean you can say easily
that Mayweather was taking those rounds
off and I agree he was and you could say
that Mayweather was bringing him to deep
water because he knew he would exhaust
him because he didn't give him enough
time to train for it because he really
only gave him two months it was very
brilliant I made with his part he knew
that he wouldn't be efficient he would
tire all those kinetic big explosive
movements that Conor likes to do they're
very taxing and he knew that he was not
gonna have the efficiency to go 12 hard
rounds with a master defensive fighter
like Mayweather and Mayweather was right
but he didn't want to get hit with that
uppercut that he got cracked with in the
first round he didn't want to like you
know Conor's movement was very unusual
it took Floyd a while to decipher it he
live been way better for him if he just
blew Conor out of the water from one
round on and just completely outclassed
him but he didn't and one of the reasons
why did mrs. Conners an extraordinary
person he has greatness he has greatness
I mean he didn't really have the proper
opportunity in in only being able to
prepare for two months and only having
this one professional boxing match there
was a lot of things stacked against him
and yet I feel although he clearly lost
he performed admirably I don't think it
hurts his stock in any way I think it
elevates him and I think his next fight
in the UFC whoever would will be will be
probably the biggest fight in UFC
history if they can do it correctly
depending upon who it is especially if
it's Nate Diaz because Nate Diaz is a
huge name and if Nate Diaz and him
decide to do it one more time I think
that would be the biggest fight ever in
history of the sport because I think
Connor has eclipsed the sport largely
you know and maybe for now maybe someone
else will come along in the next year or
two that that does it I mean look
Connors only been around for a few years
I tweeted to him in 2013 or 14 I forget
what it was when he had won a big fight
in the UK and I said you know
congratulations on an amazing
performance I really hope seeing the UFC
someday that was like four years ago oh
my god most so in four years he's gone
from being this unknown fighter that
only like the really hardcore fanatics
like myself knew about to him being this
worldwide phenomena he's the the biggest
combat sport athlete not just of today
ever there's no one like him no one like
him no one that has the kind of
popularity that he has I mean this
[ __ ] guy has thousands and thousands
of people fly from Ireland to Vegas
every time he fights the weigh-ins it
seems like you're in Dublin
I mean it's [ __ ] crazy man when you
look at what I when I interview him at
the weigh-ins in the UFC in Vegas you
look out you see nothing but Irish flags
you see people screaming and cheering
and singing Mandalay Bay during the
[ __ ] Floyd Mayweather fight which is
not even the venue where the fight was
being held Mandalay Bay was packed
bumper to bumper with Irishmen walking
down the hallway cheering and singing
songs in sync it was insane brilliant
there's no one like him so first we have
to have the greatness yeah without the
grayness who gives a [ __ ] is just
another person but like a Denny's helped
us it about Van Gogh you know like you
know it gives a [ __ ] if you cut your ear
off if you paint in the [ __ ] you've
gotta be good so he's game is good but
then like but there are often great
geniuses in sport but to have that like
you say this foot so that he used like
the romantic ideas of Ireland and he's
owned Irishness that became an important
part of his perception but it's
obviously resonating in a very very
powerful way to have that kind of
devotion
well Ireland's very important Ireland's
a very important part of the equation as
well because their appreciation and love
and and support of him is unprecedented
mean I've seen Brazilian fans that love
Josie Aldo and I've seen Brazilian fans
that love Anderson Silva and you know
the worshiped by their countrymen but it
pales in comparison to the amount of
love that Conor McGregor gets I
understand their their myth aligns with
his myth the myth of the Irish people is
being oppressed by British colonialism
and having to fight for their freedom it
resonates with what this man represents
and perhaps this is always what happens
with figures of greatness whether it's
within the realm of sport or within the
realm of politics temporarily a person
sort of captures a particular mood a
particular energy and this is what I
think again is to do with
unconsciousness I don't think people go
like a car aware of these kind of
feelings I think it's is stimulated on a
level that's not about for this is one
of the things I'm very interested in
what lies beyond the rational you know
what lies here we can equate we can work
out we can just that there seems to be
some ingredient even in Conor McGregor
that you can't quite pin down yes
there's the Ravens as a box oh yes the
Irish people you know but there's also
some flavor is being caught I wonder if
you can ever preempt or understand these
things I wonder if you can ever drill
down but like this of the work of Joseph
Campbell the work of Carl Jung the work
of these people to say are there are
unconscious archetypes there are
unconscious themes there are stories
that are running below the surface
patterns coordinates that can be
connected to some people well notably
the profession of marketing know how to
harness these energies if you have
enough people feeling then not good
enough they will spend money trying to
feel better whether it's the purchase of
a car or a coffee or whatever it is one
of the key ingredient is make people
feel not good enough if you can re
harness and redirect people's sexual
energy so that their sexual energy is
directed at products and consumerism
then you will sell your product but for
me it seems like such a shame to waste
this force to waste this knowledge to
waste this energy just to turn people
into consumers just to turn everything
on this planet into a commodity when
what we could be doing is using this
energy to imagine new worlds to imagine
new systems to use our greatness to use
our greatness to I don't know Joe love
one another
to create new tribes
[Applause]
[Music]